I thought would help our audience  members make a sale or connection  tonight by showing some of their  craigslist ads right here on the show  and this should help you out sell your  stuff okay let's check out the first ad  help needed please send the jaws of life  to get me out of this shirt for sale for  sale vegan brownies marijuana is vegan  right  want it shovel so I can turn on my way  over a taping of Ellen agent needed I'm  an aspiring actor known as Russia's  Patrick Swayze  casual encounters come over and debate  Pride and Prejudice adaptations all  night  announcement no your bangs are covering  up an embarrassing Papa Roach tattoo  finally available Moby impersonator on  the spitting image down there too  you  you